so übermorgen wird in berlin der vertrag
von frank walter steinmeier als
bundespräsident offiziell verlängert
daran gibt es original null zweifel
mangels echter gegenkandidaten ja das
ist bei uns in deutschland einfach so
eine tradition bei der wahl des
staatsoberhaupts soll so wenig spannung
aufkommen wie irgend möglich und damit
endet also steinmeiers erster amtszeit
die er selber so zusammenfasst
vermutlich haben die meisten von denen
vor allem einen wunsch
das ist vorbei sein möge endlich vorbei
sein möge und das ist nur zu
verständlich
hat er das wirklich das hat er über
corona gesagt er verstehe tatsächlich
ist der mann sehr beliebt im volk denn
er hat weisse haare was will man mehr
ein schönes haus zum beispiel meint
dietmar wischmeyer
die schnäppchenhäuser billig wohnen mit
dietmar wischmeyer live aus dem schloss
melden
liebe zuschauer
absolute traum immobilie
heute im angebot toplage marmorfußboden
und mietfrei
gehörte nämlich selber kleines problem
der jetzige bewohner wenig ausziehen
sein name frank walter steinmeier
nichtraucher unauffällig hört keine
laute musik und ist von beruf
bundespräsident mit zeitvertrag
deutschland leistet sich in dieser protz
bude einen hochbezahlten minijobber
dessen hauptaufgabe es ist hier drin zu
wohnen doch vorsicht ein frank walter
steinmeier kann auch einiges mehr und
hat ohne ende fans vor allen dingen ist
er ein mensch der den menschen als
mensch begegnet frank walter steinmeier
kann zuhören er kann reden und erkennt
schweigen nicht nur dass er kann sich
sogar alleine die schuhe zubinden und
wenn er voll auf attacke steht ist er
unsichtbar kein wunder dass die ampel
parteien auf diese fachkraft nicht
verzichten mögen und am sonntag noch mal
eine amtszeit draufsatteln die union hat
zwar kurz irgendwas weibliches gesucht
doch daraufhin haben sämtliche frauen in
deutschland ihre handys zertreten aus
angst vor einem anruf von friedrich merz
die grünen wollten nach zwölf männern im
amt auch auf jeden fall eine frau aber
bei gerade mal 40 millionen im landtag
finden alleine also bleibt uns der
pflegeleichte weiskopf noch ein paar
jahre erhalten schade eigentlich mit den
vorgängern hat mir deutlich mehr spaß
die wulffs zum beispiel unsere clintons
aus der klinker witze haben über monate
die klatschspalten versorgt gauck der
zonen jesus aus rostock war das gewissen
der nation dann brauchen wir kein
eigenes sogar otto köhler hatte seine
lichten momente das nächste spiel heißt
das spiel ist vor dem nächsten spiel
oder so ähnlich naja oder so ähnlich das
waren noch präsidenten die man
wenigstens doof finden konnte
kontroverse debatten angestoßen haben
das beste was man über all stoney sagen
kann er hat keine großen fehler gemacht
er schwitzt nicht eigentlich bemerkt man
ihn gar nicht obwohl zugegeben mit einem
interview hat er sich schon weit aus dem
fenster gelehnt sind die autos den
deutschen mehr wert das hoffe ich nicht
denn ich glaube nicht nur ich sage
kinder sind natürlich viel wichtiger als
autos aber
kinder sind natürlich auch ganz was
anderes als autos ja völlig richtig bei
der beschleunigung schlägt das auto
jedes kind bei abgaswerten würde ich
sagen unentschieden egal herzlich wird
frank-walter zur sicheren wiederwahl
übermorgen im nationalen volkskongress
aus bundestag landespolitikern und
ausgesuchten b promis und schalten sie
auch in fünf jahren wieder ein wenn es
heißt diesmal wird es aber auf jeden
fall eine art frau
die schnäppchenhäuser billig wohnen mit
dietmar wischmeyer
[Musik]
und stehe ich richtig super also dann
los
liebe fans der feinsten unterhaltung
klickt hier hin wenn ihr weitere videos
sehen wollt
das war super trägt wir haben ich sehe
auch echt clique aus heute